in season six of Game of Thrones and
hopefully soon in the books Daenerys
Targaryen sails west hoping to take the
throne of Westeros she brings with her
an army and a navy and three dragons but
her war won't be easy if done is to
succeed in a conquest she should take
some lessons from Game of Thrones
history because this is actually the
second time a Targaryen has invaded
Westeros from the east with three
dragons the first time was 300 years ago
in the conquest of Aegon Targaryen
so before Tommen and Joffrey and Robert
Baratheon the king of Westeros was Aerys
Targaryen the father of Daenerys and
Viserys before Aerys was a dozen
generations of Targaryen Kings a dynasty
of three centuries which was founded by
Aegon Targaryen Aegon's family
originally came from Valyria the Empire
of the Dragonlords but it blew up which
is kind of its own story the Targaryen
escaped this tomb and settled on
Dragonstone and Island just off Westeros
and for generations they stayed there
trading in the Narrow Sea and meddling
in eastern politics but when Aegon
became lord of Dragonstone
his interest was Westeros Westeros at
the time was divided into seven kingdoms
the North was ruled by King tauren Stark
the Vale by Queen Regent Shara Aran for
a young son Ronald the iron island from
the Riverlands ruled by King Harrenhal
the westerland's ruled by King Loren
Lannister the reach by King Mern
gardener the Stormlands by King our
galacto randon and donned by Princess
Maria Martell these kingdoms had been
fighting one another for centuries but
the way Aegon Soraa Westeros was one
realm to one King to rule alone he was
to be that King so he planned an
invasion we don't know much about Aegon
as a person he was a great warrior and
leader but he was also an enigma
reserved with few friends his closest
companions were his sisters who were
also his wives because the Targaryen
really loved incest
Visenya and Rainey's Visenya was a
skilled warrior
stoned and serious while Rainey's was
more playful and impulsive a lover of
new
dick and dancing there was also orys
baratheon Aegon's friend and possibly
his bastard half-brother the Targaryen
tired alliances with houses by Eman
kaltaka Massey and valerian old minor
houses that were based nearby to
Dragonstone and the Targaryen also had
dragons
Visenya wrote a dragon called Vega rainy
throat a dragon called neuraxis and
Aegon wrote a monster called balerion
the black dread a dragon so huge that
whole towns were swallowed up in a
shadow of his wings when he passed over
them after the destruction of Valyria
these three were the only dragons known
to exist in the world
so that was team Targaryen at the
beginning of the conquest Aegon his
sisters and their three dragons orys
baratheon debar Emin's celtic earth
masses and Valerians
they raised a small army and landed on
Westeros the place where they landed the
mouth of the Blackwater River Aegon
built a small force of the Aegon fort
Rhaenys and Visenya went and took over
the nearby small castles of Stokeworth
and Rose B which was pretty easy because
they had dragons the Lords of dusk and
Dale and maidenpool gathered an army and
marched on Aegon with three thousand men
but they gone easily destroyed them with
his dragon if you pay close attention
you might start to see a pattern here
then back at the AEGON thought they had
a ceremony where a gone let his defeated
enemies keep their old lands and
positions so long as they joined his
side Visenya crowned Aegon Rainey's
named him king of Westeros and they
unfold a Targaryen banner a red
three-headed dragon on black silk the
Targaryen xand the Valyrian ancestors
didn't have a tradition of heraldry
but Aegon used this Westerosi custom as
a way of showing he was one of them when
the Lord saw a goons banner they took it
as a sign that he was a worthy High King
for Westeros but there was still some
conquering left to do one of Aegon's
first moves was to send a fleet of ships
led by daemon Valeri on to attack gold
town and the Vale of Arryn the Erin's
got a fleet together and managed to beat
the Targaryen sinking a third of their
ships and killing daemon valerian but in
response
Visenya came and burned the Vale slate
with a dragon Vega this kind of sets the
tone for the rest of the conquest
sometime
the Targaryen did get beat but never for
long because in the end Aegon's enemies
had no answer for his dragons well
except for Dawn but we're getting ahead
of ourselves
Aegon marched on to his first real
challenge king Harrenhal house hole was
originally from the Iron Islands but
they came to rule the Riverlands as well
Heron was called of the black and was
legendary for his cruelty he built a
tremendous castle called Harrenhal and
made the river lenders pay for
plundering from the local Lords and
working thousands of people to death as
they gone approached Harrenhal with his
army he was attacked by herons men twice
in the second battle two of herand sons
managed to sneak up and kill a bunch of
Aegon's men in the night but in the
morning Aegon burned Heron sons with his
dragon as they tried to escape across a
lake Heron tried to rally the river
Lords to help him fight but instead they
rose up against him under the leadership
of the Lord Edmund Tully suddenly
outnumbered Herron retreated to his
castle when Aegon came he offered her in
peace said if he gave up he'd let him go
home to the Iron Islands he said he had
8,000 men outside heron's walls Harun
said what's outside of his walls is of
no concern because his walls are strong
and thick Aegon said that I have dragons
dragons fly Aaron said stone doesn't
burn so Aegon said when the Sun sets
your line shall end when night fell
Aegon descended on Harrenhal with his
dragon bathing its towers in fire until
they began to melt like candles
everything inside was caught on fire
wood and wool hemp and straw and all of
herons men the greatest castle in
Westeros was made a ruin that night and
Haran died along with his entire line in
the morning the river Lords pledged
their allegiance to Aegon and Edmund
Tully was named Lord paramount of the
Trident the ancestor of hosta Brendan
catland Lysa and Ed Miller as the
Harrenhal it's twisted melted ruins are
now believed to be cursed almost every
character who holds Harrenhal in the
main story has ended up violently
murdered Littlefinger and Roose Bolton
in the books are two of the only ones to
survive
so far that yeah Aegon defeated
Harrenhal and took the Riverlands the
Iron Islands Aegon kind of ignored for a
few years but later he came back and
sort of them out and allowed them to
pick their own leader they chose Vikon
gradually ancestor of Bellinger on Iran
Asha or Yara and Theon while Aegon took
the river lamps Rainey's and horas went
to take the Stormlands on their way to
the castle of storms end they were
ambushed by Argyll ax men who killed a
thousand Targaryen soldiers before
melting back into the forests so
Rainey's boned the forests killed the
men and kept on marching by now king
argilac had heard what had happened to
Haran so he decided to leave his castle
and attack the Targaryen Zin the field
from Dragon bahraini saw them coming so
she and orey's from the Targaryen army
dug in and waited for them to come right
on cue a huge dramatic storm began a
steady rain became a howling gale
setting the stage for a massive battle
later called the last storm because of
the storm rain eases dragon maroc seas
couldn't fly so the battle was actually
a pretty fair fight enraged well into
the night with Argyll actually Targaryen
swith cavalry and spearmen until he
finally broke through to his enemy
center and was faced with rainy sand
MARAC seized the dragon burned a Galax
best man and scattered his cavalry a
Naga Lac was killed in single combat
with horas para thean the battle ended
and after a brief resistance by our
Galax daughter our gala the Stormlands
were one for Aegon or eise married our
gala and took the Girondin Castle sigil
and house words for his own and so the
house Baratheon was founded ancestors of
Robert Stannis Renly and don't forget
Robert's bastard Gendry on the other
side of Westeros
the kings of the Westlands and the reach
Loren Lannister and Mern gardener
decided that enough was enough they
raised the biggest army ever seen in
Westeros over 50,000 strong and marched
on the Targaryen Aegon with his much
smaller army came to meet them and they
clashed in a field of wheat and grass
which egg on noted was very dry it
hadn't rained in a while the battle
began bloke started killing blokes but
then the Targaryen is activated their
trap card which was it well
they're dragons Rhaenys and Visenya
started big fires to the sides and
behind of the enemy trapping them while
balerion filled the enemy lines with
flame and smoke thousands of men were
burned alive in what was later called
the field of fire King Loren Lannister
managed to escape he surrendered to
Aegon and was made warden of the West
ancestor dat eye when Tyrion Cersei and
Jaime but King Mern and his family were
all wiped out ending house gardener who
had ruled the reach for thousands of
years control of the reach then fell to
Harlem of house Tyrell who had served
the gardeners as stewards for many years
Hollen immediately surrendered to Aegon
and so was given dominion over the reach
as a khan's warden of the south
interestingly it's implied at least in
the blu-ray features for the show that
it was the Tyrells idea for the
gardener's to go get themselves killed
so that the Tyrells could take over to
these schemers are the ancestors of
Margaery mace and Loras after the region
westerland's were conquered Aegon heard
the Northman were on the March
so he rushed up with all his army to
meet King Turin stock Turin had a pretty
big army with 30,000 Northman but he saw
that Aegon's was bigger a huge host of
rebel Landers storm lenders Westerlund
as richmond everyone he had conquered
and won over to his side Turin saw
Aegon's dragons and heard how they'd
burned thousands on the field of fire
and at Harrenhal and Turin thought do we
really want to fight these guys some of
his bannermen wanted to attack others
wanted to fall back to moat Cailin
torrents busted brother Brandon Snow
offered to sneak into Aegon's camp and
try to kill his dragons but in the end
Turin decided to make peace he knelt
gave up his crown and swore the north to
Aegon forever after torn was known as
the king who knelt and he start
descendants were no longer kings of
winter but only wardens of the north
some Northland were angry that their
king would surrender but it's hard to
deny turin saved the north from a war
they probably wouldn't have won still
this Brandon Snow thing is interesting
torrents brother offered to cross the
Trident alone under cover of darkness to
slay Aegon's dragons while they slept
with this guy brave or stupid
he has a plan to kill these dragons
there is a bit in dance that could give
a hint of what Brandon was thinking bran
Stark has a vision of the distant past
where he sees a pale fierce youth in the
Winterfell godswood slicing three
branches of where wood off the heart
tree and shaping them into arrows some
fans believe that that youth is Brandon
Snow and speculate that these three
weirwood arrows could have had some
power to kill Aegon's three dragons we
would his link to the magic of the old
gods and the children of the forest so
there isn't much to go on here but it is
an interesting possibility maybe dragon
killing where would arrows will come
back into the story at some point in the
Vale Queen Regent Shara
Aran had just seen five of Westeros as
Seven Kingdoms fall to Aegon so she
raised her defenses she put a strong
army at the bloody gate and Garrison's
all of the ire either reputedly
impregnable castle of the hour and kings
but all the defenses turned out to be
useless when Visenya flew over them I'm
dragging back easily landing in the iris
in a courtyard when Queen Shara ran out
to face her with her guards she found
her son Ronald sitting on visenya zni
asking for a ride on the dragon in the
end Shara and Visenya had a nice chat
Ronald got a ride on the dragon and when
he landed he was no longer a little King
but a little Lord the veil yielded to
Aegon and joined his realm after the
veil there was one Kingdom left to
conquer Rainey's mounted her dragon
MARAC seized and flew out to the sands
of dawn she came to the castle of faith
and flew down to take it but it was
empty
none of the lords or guards were there
and the peasants wouldn't say where they
went
so Rainey's flew onto God's grace then
planky town but could find only women
and children finally she came to
Sunspear home of the Martell princes of
dawn and found it too abandoned except
for the princess of dawn herself Miriam
are tell Mary o was old and fat and
blind some called her the yellow toad of
dawn but she was still very sharp Maria
told Rainey's that she wouldn't fight
but she wouldn't kneel that the Martell
house words are unbowed unbent unbroken
she said that Dawn has no king that
Rainey's isn't wanted in Dorne
and to return at her peril so rain is
left and Dawn remained unconquered
rainiest did come back in another
Targaryen attack 10 years later and when
she did Rhaenys was killed
a scorpion bolt pierced my Roxy's eye
and the Dragon and the Queen fell from
the sky every time the Targaryen tried
to take dawn dawn beat them by using
these guerrilla tactics
whenever the dragons came the Dornish
wouldn't line up to be roasted like at
the field of fire they would instead
vanish melt away leaving only stone and
sand for them to burn emerging when it
was safe to kill their enemies from the
shadows
it wasn't till over a hundred years
later that don't finally joined the
Seven Kingdoms and even then it wasn't
by conquest but by diplomacy and
marriage Don joined Westeros on their
own terms and attitude upheld by some of
Mario's descendants including Oberyn
torrone Elia and Tristan so Aegon failed
to conquer dawn but six out of seven
kingdoms ain't bad he came to old town
the biggest city in Westeros and the
center of the faith of the seven which
is like the Catholic Church of Game of
Thrones the High Septon kind of the Pope
had spent seven days and seven nights
praying to the gods for advice on Aegon
and eventually he decided that he would
not fight the guy with the dragons were
just conquered much of the country but
would declare him the rightful ruler so
the Septon anointed Aegon with seven
oils placed a crown upon his head and
proclaimed him Aegon of House Targaryen
the first of his name king of the Andals
the Roy now in the first men lord of the
Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm
Aegon decided to rule his great new
realm from the new town that was growing
round to Aegon fort which eventually
would become the city of King's Landing
Aegon made a thrown out of the swords of
his defeated enemies that Iron Throne
which looks a lot cooler in the books so
that is how Aegon conquered Westeros
what candan Aerys one from this the
first most obvious lesson is that her
most valuable assets are her dragons she
can use them to destroy enemy castles
and armies and fleets to control
battlefields to scout ahead to
intimidate they'll probably be very
useful against the white walkers but
Daenerys will have to be careful to
protect her
they can be killed as Rainey's learned
in dawn a scorpion bolt can kill one and
historically they've also been killed by
arrows even by mobs of angry peasants if
they get trapped indoors there might
also be the risk of somehow losing
control over one of her dragons in the
books
you're on Greyjoy has a magic horn that
he claims can bind dragons to his will
there's also speculation that bran or
the night king could do some skin
changing magic shenanigans to take one
of Danny's dragons just like bran wargs
Hodor and the walkers control White's
basically there are a lot of things that
could go wrong with the Dragons and
honestly Daniel probably lose at least
one of them somehow that story I'd be
boring if you just easily one with them
right
also Dany should watch out for guerrilla
tactics like the Targaryen faced in
Dorne
she's already come up against this sort
of thing with the sons of the harpy in
Mereen who hide in the day and strike at
night and Danny wasn't much good at
dealing with these guys the basic
problem is that dragons are great at
killing your enemies but only if you
know who your enemies are
and where they are and sadly in the game
of Thrones
things aren't always so straightforward
something else Danny might want to think
about is political and cultural
legitimacy Aegon was really smart in
using symbols and traditions that showed
he'd be a worthy ruler that he would
rule not of some Valyrian foreign
overlord but as a westerosi king he used
Westerosi heraldry he was anointed by
the leader of Westeros irreligion and he
built a huge visible tangible symbol of
his political power in the Iron Throne
using the actual swords of his enemies
to embody his right of conquest all
these things contributed to a gods
legitimacy in the eyes of the people he
ruled to make him the sort of leader
that people were happy to follow Danny
should consider this stuff too she has
spent almost all her life far from
Westeros and she leads a mostly foreign
army so there's a risk that people will
see her not as a rightful queen but as a
foreign conqueror one easy way to
improve this is to remind everyone as
she already often does that she is the
blood of Valyria a descendent of Aegon
and the inheritor of his dynasty she
might not want to remind everyone how
though that her father was the
notoriously cruel and crazy Mad King who
Robert fought a rebellion to assert so
if she might want to be sensitive there
another interesting issue for Danny is
religion Danny seems to have no interest
in the fate of the seven and besides
that the High Septon just got blown up
in the show so the fates probably in
disarray anyway but Danny is making
connections to the red God the Lord of
Light she is rubbing shoulders with red
priests who claims she's a Zora hi this
might help get a support in Essos but
most Westerosi don't follow the red God
so this could actually work against her
here she'll want to be careful with this
but finally part of what made Aegon so
successful was that he didn't just
destroy all these enemies with dragon
fire he always offered mercy so long as
his foes bent the knees he'd even let
them keep their lands and titles Aegon
turned his enemies into allies Robert
Baratheon did the same thing but will
Daenerys be so merciful she's been
pretty Bernie lately more fire and blood
and peace and diplomacy in the show she
talks about breaking the wheel
destroying the Great Houses of Westeros
rather than winning them over to her
side Aegon the conquerer brought fire
and blood to Westeros but afterwards he
gave them peace prosperity and justice
will Dany do the same or will she bring
only death and ruin we'll have to wait
and see
thanks for watching a lot of these
beautiful illustrations and most of the
information are from the world of Ice
and Fire
Georgia Martin spoke about the history
and cultures and locations of the world
of Game of Thrones if you'd like to
check out the book there's a link to buy
it below which help support this channel
at no extra cost to you thanks also to
something like a lawyer and Brendan B
fish of wars and politics of Ice and
Fire for helping out with this video
script you can find some amazing
in-depth Game of Thrones analysis at
their blog there's a link below a thanks
offered to the patrons supporting this
channel on patreon including Bartok
psychotic oyster erica Campbell and a
jazz herb cam Lewis momma QB Scott
Dedham and Bruno Johnson for the watch
and Ricky Cheers
you